[Music]
was Angelina Jolie caught in a lie the
oscar-winning actress is in a
high-profile fight with Vanity Fair over
its September cover story the war of
words started after the magazine
reported on the audition process for
Jolie's upcoming Netflix film about
Cambodia these are really interesting
people the article described it like
this quote the casting director set up a
game rather disturbing in its realism
they put money on the table and ask the
child to think of something she needed
the money for and then to snatch it away
the story went viral in online critics
attacked Jolie calling her cruel and
monstrous and said the process sounded
like a kind of orphan Hunger Games
Angelina fired back in a statement
calling it false and upsetting that
people misinterpreted a pretend exercise
as if it was a real scenario and there's
another twist we're just learning about
Jolie got her attorney involved
yesterday Vanity Fair claimed Jolie's
lawyer asked the magazine to remove the
audition paragraph from its online story
and publish a correction the magazine
refused and did something bold it
released a transcript of the interview
it seemed to support the magazine's
claim that Jolie suggested that two
children were not fully aware that they
were playing a game one excerpt quote
they didn't know what they were really
doing Jolie did not return our request
for comment today
Vanity Fair says it stands by its story
[Music]
you